In this segment, we will discuss
what a sequence is and
what it means for a sequence
to converge.
So a sequence is nothing but
some collection of elements
that are coming out of some set,
and that collection of
elements is indexed by
the natural numbers.
We often use the notation, and
we say that we have a sequence
ai, or sometimes we use the
notation that we have a
sequence of this kind to
emphasize the fact that it's a
sequence and not just
a single number.
And what we mean by this is that
we have i, an index that
runs over the natural numbers,
which is the set of positive
integers, and each ai is
an element of some set.
In many cases, the set is going
to be just the real
line, in which case we're
dealing with a sequence of
real numbers.
But it is also possible that
the set over which our
sequence takes values is
Euclidean space n-dimensional
space, in which case
we're dealing with
a sequence of vectors.
But it also could be any
other kind of set.
Now, the definition that
I gave you may
still be a little vague.
You may wonder how a
mathematician would define
formally a sequence.
Formally, what a sequence is,
is just a function that, to
any natural number, associates
an element of S. In
particular, if we evaluate the
function f at some argument i,
this gives us the ith element
of the sequence.
So that's what a sequence is.
Now, about sequences, we
typically care whether a
sequence converges to some
number a, and we often use
this notation.
But to make it more precise,
you also add
this notation here.
And we read this as saying
that as i converges to
infinity, the sequence
ai converges to a
certain number a.
A more formal mathematical
notation would be the limit as
i goes to infinity of ai is
equal to a certain number, a.
But what exactly
does this mean?
What does it mean for a
sequence to converge?
What is the formal definition?
It is as follows.
Let us plot the sequence
as a function of i.
So this is the i-axis, and here
we plot entries of ai.
For a sequence to converge to a
certain number a, we need to
the following to happen.
If we draw a small band around
that number a, what we want is
that the elements of the
sequence, as i increases,
eventually get inside
this band and stay
inside that band forever.
Now, let us turn this into
a more precise statement.
What we mean is the following.
If I give you some positive
number epsilon, and I'm going
to use that positive number
epsilon to define a band
around the number a.
So it's this band here.
If I give you a positive number
epsilon, and therefore,
this way, have defined a certain
band, there exists a
time after which the entries
will get the inside the band.
In this picture, it would
be this time.
So there exists a time--
let's call that time i0--
so i0 is here such that after
that time, what we have is
that the element of
the sequence is
within epsilon of a.
So this is the formal definition
of convergence of a
sequence to a certain
number a.
The definition may look
formidable and difficult to
parse, but what it
says in plain
English is pretty simple.
No matter what kind of band
I take around my limit a,
eventually, the sequence will
be inside this band and will
stay inside there.
Convergence of sequences has
some very nice properties that
you're probably familiar with.
For example, if I tell you
that a certain sequence
converges to a number a and
another sequence converges to
a number b, then we will have
that ai plus bi, which is a
new sequence--
the ith element of the sequence
is this sum--
will converge to a plus b.
Or similarly, ai times bi, which
is another sequence,
converges to a times b.
And if, in addition, g is a
continuous function, then g of
ai will converge to g of a.
So for example, if the ais
converge to a, then the
sequence ai squared is going
to converge to a squared.